tu m'appelles eva je suis co fondatrice
de gras politique et aujourd'hui je vais
vous parler de bourses aux phobies il
forcément de la grossophobie un peu
partout au quotidien que tu sors de chez
toi tu as ton voisin qui te regardent un
peu chelou parce que tu es la bourse de
services
tu descends tu t'achètes un pain au
chocolat ou un croissant parce que il
faut que tu aller au boulot et a pas le
temps t'as pas le temps de prendre ton
p'tit déj chez toi tu es à la bourre tu
cours tu dois prendre ton métro un
effort les petits regarde pas très bon
pour ce que vous avez vous prenez plutôt
croissance en beurre après tu dois
prendre le métro bombe alors déjà et
pour les tourniquets moi je passe de
profits parce que deux phases ne passe
pas ensuite j'arrive au boulot je mets
ma tenue travail en atelier de travail
elle n'est pas adaptée parce qu'elle
n'existe pas à ma taille et après voilà
il ya tout ce qui concerne qu'on
pourrait qualifier de harcèlement
quotidien de rue ça grands classiques
mais où moi ça fait j'ai trente deux ans
a fait globalement 30 ans que je suis au
bez donc je fais plus vraiment attention
[Musique]
je suis une personne grosse et ça me
défrise pas con qu'on m'appelle grosse
puisque c'est ce que je suis c'est pas
une insulte c'est un adjectif
qualificatif
on peut l'utiliser sans aucun problème
il des frises en revanche c'est toutes
les idées reçues c'est parce que je suis
grosse on va me dire oui mais tu es
feignante c'est parce que je suis grosse
qu'on n'a pas m'embaucher parce que
parce que essaha véridique
si je te mets en salle les clients vont
pas vouloir prendre de desserts dont tu
vas pas me vendre de dessert c'est
l'urbanisme qui n'est pas adapté parce
que par exemple l'urbanisme anti sdf
c'est aussi un urbanisme anti gros c'est
à dire que moi les sièges où il ya des
accoudoirs et ben je rentre pas dedans
par exemple donc
rien n'est fait aujourd'hui pour que les
gros puissent vivre normalement dans la
société nous agra politiques ont fait
pas on fait pas la promotion d'obésité
on peut dire que les gros sont malades
on peut dire que les personnes obèses
sont malades il ya effectivement des
comorbidités associées à l'obésité c'est
pourquoi on me dit c'est pour la fin de
la grossophobie et on est assez persuadé
que ce sera concomitant avec la fin de
l'obésité ou une diminution l'obésité
parce qu'aujourd'hui on est 20 %
d'obèses aux docks double de baisse ou
de gros en france
et quand on regarde comment naît un gros
on se rend compte que la grossophobie à
une grande part dans la création du gros
alors pas que effectivement il ya une
part d'hérédité que sa part d'hérédité
génétique ou une part d'hérédité
culturel et si on veut vous soigner il
va falloir arrêter de taper sur les gros